THE 31-YEAR-OLD CARLSEN STILL
WON THE SEPTEMBER 20th MATCH
DESPITE WITHDRAWING.
NEIMANN WHO IS 19, ADMITTED TO
CHEATING EARLIER IN HIS CAREER
BUT NOT ANY WRONGDOING NOW.
THE INTERNATIONAL CHESS
FEDERATION REPRIMANDED CARLSEN
SAYING THERE WERE BETTER WAYS TO
HANDLE THE SITUATION.
>>> WHAT IS TICKED OFF?
SOME "JEOPARDY!" FANS ARE MORE
THAN A LITTLE PEEVED THAT A
MAJOR CHANGE COULD BE COMING TO
THE GAME SHOW.
THOUGH IT IS JUST AN IDEA RIGHT
NOW.
EXECUTIVE PRODUCER MIKE DAVIES
HAS SUGGESTED THAT CASH BONUSES
COULD BE AWARDED TO CONTESTANTS
WHO SUCCESSFULLY SWEEP A FULL
CATEGORY AND YOU GET TO KEEP
THAT BONUS MONEY WHETHER OR NOT
YOU WIN THE GAME AS A WHOLE.
WITH US NOW, FORMER "JEOPARDY!"
CHAMPION, AUSTIN ROGERS, GREAT
TO SEE YOU.
>> THANK YOU, JOHN.
>> TALK TO ME ABOUT WHY YOU
THINK THEY'RE SUGGESTING THIS,
THAT THEY WOULD GIVE YOU A BONUS
IF YOU RUN THE WHOLE CATEGORY.
>> LET'S GO BACK TO THE HISTORY
OF THE GAME.
BACK IN THE DAY IN THE OLDEN
TIMES, YOU USED TO PLAY LYNN
LARLY.
AND THE WRITERS WRITE THEIR
CATEGORY TOP DOWN.
THEY'RE CREATING A LITTLE
NARRATIVE THEY WANT TO TAKE THE
PLAYERS AND THE VIEWERS ALONG
WITH.
THE EXAMPLE I GIVE IS IF AT THE
TOP OF A CATEGORY IT MIGHT SAY
MATTERHORN, AND YOU MIGHT GO IS
IT BATTERHORN OR MONT BLANC AND
AT THE BOTTOM THEY HAVE THE
OPPOSITE ONE.
AND YOU'LL ONLY LEARN THAT IF
YOU GO DOWN THE CATEGORY.
NOW, OF COURSE, IS THAT THE BEST
WAY TO PLAY?
NO.
YOU WANT TO OPTIMIZE WITH WHAT
THE SO-CALLED FOREST BOUNCE,
HUNTING, PICKING, BUILDING UP
MONEY AND GOING TARGETED FOR THE
DAILY DOUBLE.
SO, WE'RE GOING TO HAVE SOME
"JEOPARDY!" PEOPLE DOWN THE ROAD
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT IS THE
RIGHT WAY TO PLAY, GO FOR THE
BONUSES OR GO FOR THE HUNT AND
PICK AND THE HUNT AND PICK --
HUNT, PICK DAILY DOUBLE MODEL.
>> RIGHT.
SO, AGAIN, WHEN YOU RUN THE
CATEGORY, THE SHOW LIKES IT
BECAUSE IT TELLS A BETTER STORY
AND THE VIEWER CAN STAY FOCUSED
ON ONE THING.
BUT WHAT PEOPLE HAVE BEEN DOING
LATELY IS LOOKING FOR THE DAILY
DOUBLE, GOING ACROSS, HUNTING
AND PICKING WHICH SAY LITTLE BIT
DISJOINTED.
THE SHOW CAN'T TELL YOU HOW TO
PLAY.
BUT THEY SEEM TO BE
INCENTIVIZING THE CATEGORY
OPTION HERE.
YOU'LL GET A LITTLE EXTRA MONEY
IF YOU DO IT THIS WAY.
>> THAT MONEY WILL NOT AFFECT
THE ULTIMATE WINNER, SO IN
MICHAEL DAVIES LITTLE STATEMENT
IT WAS, HEY, MAYBE THEY'LL GIVE
THEIR SECOND AND THIRD PLACE
FINISHERS SOMETHING ELSE TO GO
FOR, AN EXTRA CARROT RATHER THAN
EXTRA STICK ON GETTING BEATEN.
I THINK IT IS REALLY GOING TO BE
FUN FOR THE WRITERS AND FUN FOR
US TO FOLLOW ALONG.
>> SOME PEOPLE ON TWITTER
BECAUSE THIS IS WHAT PEOPLE DO
ON TWITTER HAVE BEEN TICKED OFF.
YOU CAN'T DO THIS.
YOU CAN'T CHANGE THIS.
YOU CAN'T ADD SOMETHING NEW NOW.
>> "JEOPARDY!" PLAYERS ARE
TYPICALLY ON THE RISK AVERSE
SIDE.
THAT'S WHY WHEN WE SEE OPTIMUM
"JEOPARDY!" PLAYERS, IT IS SUCH
AN OUTLIER.
IN THE RUN OF THE MILL DAY TO
DAY AUDIENCE IN, AUDIENCE OUT
SHOW TAPINGS OF "JEOPARDY!" MOST
PEOPLE DO TRY TO START AT THE
TOP AND MOVE THEIR WAY DOWN TO
THE BOTTOM.
SO I DON'T THINK WE'RE GOING TO